so for this week's video we decided to
go a unique route and we were thinking
about how cool it would be to shoot an
underwater fight scene where it's
actually a max payne piece the catch is
we couldn't afford to rent a super high
speed camera to get the slow motion
bullet time jumps and dives and that
kind of stuff those cameras are like a
hundred thousand dollars incentive camp
with unique solution and shot in a
friend's swimming pool and used the
underwater footage cut it out and put it
into real life footage to actually get
the slow motion effect kind of ran at
the concept it made the whole piece kind
of revolve around max payne having
hallucinations while he's basically
drowning in the water it was a unique
approach i think it worked really well
and gives the piece a really unique look
it's not even about whether or not we're
trying to get like a slow-mo camera for
the shoot it's just kind of what can we
do underwater like what cool underwater
stuff can we do so we went to our friend
annie mogren's pool and spent the entire
night swimming in the water i was
treading water with the 17 underwater
housing for like eight hours yeah that
was a very very rough night probably
have seen this stuff maybe if you've
seen bear force one or
werewolf in the girls sorority yeah you
should check out andy's channel some
really good stuff also thanks to uh ian
and arthur definitely for coming out and
helping as well as paolo and jan you
might know jan is the bad guy from
dubstep guns yeah so we just swam a lot
and uh did everybody else do a lot of
swimming swimming
all night swimming
how does it feel
wet
i'm weird i've never been
in water with
oh yeah holding your breath under water
while trying to shoot
that's a whole subject there because
we're like trying to invent hands saying
those words like
and it's like what
and then i'm like
and he's like yeah i know i know i'm
like
like come up
come up out the water
and one of the shots when uh one of the
guys takes a shotgun and blasted at max
payne and you see all the pellets
complying by the camera
we actually use an air cannon to
create an actual practical dust
explosion on the couch and having a
couple of practical effects in your shot
enhances everything all the cg gets
better and of course all the practical
stuff looks great so whenever you get
the chance you should always try to have
at least one practical element because
it definitely makes things better every
shot underwater we uh we actually we
draped a green screen behind everyone in
hopes of
getting an easy keying solution like oh
yeah just click on green
key out well there's a lot of things
going on first off everyone's clothing
is rippling second of all there's a lot
of like haze all the lights
going through the top of the water and
refracting and shining patterns on
everything made it so that the colors
and like the brightness of everything
was constantly changing so what ended up
happening is we just kind of bit the
bullet and we're like all right
let's rotoscope everything
[Music]
very painful process
though it's not so bad rotoscoping
something when they're in front of like
a solid background yeah the road of rush
in after effects
has been like a dream come true for like
10 years we would always be saying i
can't wait until the day there's an
automatic where this is automated yeah
and it's finally here it's not it's not
completely automatic yet but it's way
better yeah it used to be like hoping
for a flying car and then having it
actually
so the light going through the water was
causing the that cool light pattern to
happen on people now
in terms of compositing people into
non-underwater scenarios that's kind of
a big giveaway to have all the light
rippling so we actually kind of embraced
it and used a noise pattern in after
effects uh fractal noise swirly to be
specific swirly swirly um and we
actually put that on the background so
when it goes in the bullet time you
actually see the light pattern kind of
on everything and it brings it all
together and gives it this really unique
look yeah for this piece basically
there's a couple layers that you have to
consider uh obviously when people shoot
guns in slow motion it makes a big old
ripple through the air it's like
ripples it's kind of cool
bullet trails
put displacement map on bullet trails
basically just taking those little long
smoke elements
makes it look like it's bullet time the
underwater stuff we actually used a 7d
uh we wanted to use our scarlet we
couldn't hunt down a case and that kind
of stuff in time just because all these
youtube videos are such short notice to
go hunting down a
big gigantic underwater case that we
could afford was a little tricky i don't
know like the focus focusing on it was a
huge issue though because the thing is
like you're dealing with like little
bubbles in the foreground and you're
trying to use like the little press
focus button on it and it's like always
like half of our shots are kind of out
of focus for this because of the fact
that there's no like manual way to focus
a 7d when you don't have access to the
controls anyways guys we also uh we
actually crossed a million subscribers
this week this marks our first video
being released after getting a million
subscribers so
big thanks to all y'all
i hope you guys keep enjoying the movies
we're enjoying making them and we'll
continue striving to
impress and dazzle
our videos feel free to follow us on
twitter ask us questions talk to us we
respond back as often as we can we read
every twitter post that comes at us like
us on facebook we post sweet pictures
there and because we crossed a million
subscribers
we're probably be doing a
video game giveaway
more details on that to follow i don't
know yeah it might be on twitter it
might be on facebook maybe on twitter
maybe on facebook you'll probably have
to check out both yeah we'll see
actually you should check out facebook
right now because there's gonna be some
sweet behind the scenes photos and the
whole process as well
all right i guess that's it lunch time
[Music]
you